I'm Pritha I'm a fellow this year at the
Berkman Klein Center and I'm also a
research associate at the Harvard School
of Public Health in the Department of
Social and Behavioral Sciences. I am
looking at how population health can be
improved with the use of technology, and
in particular in low and middle income
countries, or the sort of "disadvantaged"
populations in high-income countries and
in this I am looking especially at
maternal health outcomes. So if I talk
about recent events, we have this universal identification system in
India called Aadhaar which is being
linked to track people and that has
potentially a lot of use in public
health. So for example our TB program
tuberculosis program, the financial
assistance that is provided is being
linked through that. The privacy
implications of this are really huge so
I guess, what technology can do
we should also be wary of those
very same things at the same time so
that balance is I don't know how we
are going to find it, I'm working on it
myself.
So the potential is huge, but if you say
like in a country like India, if you say
that you're not going to provide the
services if a person does not have that
ID yet that is because you have to
understand implementation is a huge
challenge. So that is a problem and secondly the
privacy part of it really scares me,
because you're linking all sorts of data
through this one ID, and the government
has access to all of it. I don't
think enough is being done to address
that, or even research on that
of how to mitigate those concerns. Like
how can you use the technology for the
good, but also reassure citizens. There should be a mechanism to
protect the privacy of citizens and I
don't think enough is being done
on that front yet.